[Music]
let's talk about Bernie this is your new
film and yeah we'll get to the what it's
about in just a second but I was
impressed I know you can sing but you
sing some gospel music in this and you
do a nice job thank you yeah I had never
sung gospel before you know raised a Jew
I didn't sing the songs of Christ but
the interesting thing is that singing it
came very naturally and I figured out
why it's kind of the other side of the
coin of heavy metal because when you
think about it metal is all about
Antichrist right and there would be no
Antichrist without Christ yeah and there
would be no gospel no there would be no
metal without gospel yes and the the
tour's kind of cogent and if you're a
true musician in that field you've got
to know both sides of the coin very can
we please play a little clip of me
saying gospel yeah watch I think we have
a clip from the movie of
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what was shed for me and that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi
and the melody service you are getting
kicked out of that Jewish school can we
just they're not watching watching now
you play in this film this is an actual
real story you play a convicted murderer
I'm gonna become really Jewish I'm
looking forward to reconnecting with my
roots
yeah Bar Mitzvah don't worry well you're
not getting any what was that question
problem with that Jewish school I'll
talk to him yeah listen Colonel Brian's
in good it there yeah yeah yeah yeah
including the fire the purpose take a
peek the ball that hit the cat nah too
late now you're ruining it